what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime outpour and today i will be
discussing
one of the most tragic and best written
protagonists
in anime and manga the often
underappreciated main character of
attack on titan
aaron jaeger aaron's character
development
is absolutely incredible and it is as
heartbreaking
as it is shocking i've already done a
bunch of videos in this tragic life
of series including videos on reiner
escanor and zelda's from some deadly
sins
inosuke from demon slayer and so on but
perhaps the single most tragic character
of the modern generation of anime manga
is none other
than aaron jaeger obviously i'm not
forgetting guts from berserk
but berserk started like back in the
1980s in
this video i will explore the staggering
evolution of aaron's character
and i will argue that he is one of the
best written tragic characters
in anime just like attack on titan
itself is one of the best written tragic
war stories
of all time if you enjoyed the attack on
titan videos on this channel and you
want us to keep it going
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to this channel or maybe you just
haven't subscribed
please consider subscribing and hitting
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking the bell
and then selecting the option that says
all
if you don't you're still gonna miss a
lot of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar finally this video will of
course contain
attack on titan manga spoilers in order
to talk about the full extent of aaron's
character development i have to also
talk about the very latest events in the
manga
so with that said please proceed with
caution
you have been warned during the course
of the attack on titan story
we see aaron go from a naive and
idealistic child
to a dark anti-hero and some would argue
a murderous villain aaron goes from a
kid who just wanted to be free from the
giant walls that confined him for his
entire life
to a cold and calculating mass murderer
who launches an apocalypse young aaron
daydreams about being free venturing
beyond the walls
and discovering the outside world but
stopping him from achieving his dream
are the titans giant mindless monsters
who roam the world
beyond the walls and who for some
unknown reason
are determined to eat every human who
ventures
into their domain faced with such a
terrifying threat
most people would never even think about
going beyond the walls
they would probably thank god every
single day that the walls
exist and the very idea of leaving the
safety of the walls
would be an act of pure madness for most
ordinary people
but aaron was never an ordinary person
and even as a child he dreamed of
joining the survey corps the only branch
of the military that is allowed to
explore the outside world
despite the fact that the survey corps
members risk their lives
every time they leave the walls and
despite the fact that many of them don't
come back alive
aaron is still determined to become one
of them despite the objections of his
mother and
others who are close to him in this
early part of his life
the major villains that aaron hated more
than anything else in the world
were these giant monsters known as the
titans
the titans were the biggest obstacle to
aaron's goal of being free
and exploring the outside world so it
makes sense that he would hate them
but aaron's hatred for the titans
intensifies
exponentially after walmaria is breached
and aaron's own mother
is eaten by a titan before his very eyes
since that day aaron swore that he would
save humanity
by destroying every single titan however
it is important to mention that even as
a child aaron had been exposed to
another
major villain another potential monster
and that monster was of course his
fellow man
from the bullies who mistreated armin to
the oppressive government
to the kidnappers who murdered mikasa's
parents the story was telling us from
the very beginning that
titans were not the only threat in this
world
in fact after he goes with his father to
a house call
aaron is put in a position where he
himself had to commit murder
in order to rescue a young girl named
mikasa from the same criminals who had
murdered her parents
after this harrowing experience aaron
forms a close connection with mikasa
but we can't ignore all these extreme
traumas that aaron had already
experienced in just the first
decade of his life he witnessed the
murder of his own mother
and many other innocent people during
the fall of shiganchina and he was put
in a position where he himself had to
commit murder
in order to save an innocent person
these events alone
are enough trauma to last a lifetime and
in many ways
these events shaped aaron's personality
from this point forward
it is also worth noting that aaron loses
his father grisha around this
same time but it isn't immediately clear
why
or what happened to his father aaron
only learns the truth
much later in the story after the fall
of shiganchina
aaron dedicates his life to saving
humanity
and eradicating the titans after
undergoing
intense military training he decides to
risk his life
on a daily basis by joining the survey
corps
mikasa who owes her life to aaron and
who is also
let's face it in love with aaron decides
to follow him wherever he goes
but it isn't long before aaron learns
that he himself
is somehow able to transform into a
titan
it's easy for us to forget now how much
of a shock that would have been for
aaron
back then remember that titans killed
his mother and destroyed
his childhood he dedicated his entire
life
to fighting them he vowed to eradicate
them and now
somehow he has become one of them as a
result
aaron suddenly finds himself being
hunted as a monster by the very humans
that he swore to protect
this situation makes aaron question his
whole identity his whole
history and to an extent he begins to
hate
himself through no fault of his own he
has become
everything that he has vowed to destroy
but in spite of this shocking
development
aaron decides to keep pushing on
he decides to use his newfound ability
to transform into a titan to fight
other titans so even as he himself
turns out to be a titan shifter aaron
still maintains his obsession
with destroying the titans along this
journey of fighting the titans
aaron loses many close friends and
comrades in the most
gruesome ways and on top of that he
suffers terrible betrayals
at the hands of some of the people he
trusted including his comrades
reiner bertolt and annie in the face of
all of this trauma and all of these
challenges aaron continues to
fight on he continues to be driven by
this idea that if only he could defeat
all the bad guys all of these titan
monsters
then everything would be better then he
could move on from all the suffering and
all the trauma that has been controlling
his
life for years however aaron and the
other
scouts eventually learn the awful truth
every single titan including the pure
titans who are not shifters
were at one point normal human beings
what's more after the basement reveal
aaron learns that the people who became
titans were turned
into those titans against their will
these people were
aldians just like aaron and the other
people in parodies and they were
forcibly turned
into titans by the oppressive and cruel
military
regime of a rival nation aaron and the
scouts come to realize that every time
they killed a pure titan
they were killing an innocent person a
fellow eldian
and someone who likely didn't do
anything to deserve their cruel
fate just imagine going through that
psychologically
after working for years to kill as many
titans as possible
thinking that every time you do kill a
titan you're doing a good thing and
making the world a better place
you eventually realized that every time
you killed a titan you were actually
killing an innocent person who did
nothing to deserve
such a cruel end now of course we know
that when the scouts kill
titans they kill them in self-defense or
in defense of other people
but it can't feel good to realize that
these monsters you were so eager to
destroy
were once normal people just like you
normal human beings who in most cases
were completely innocent of
any real wrong doing once the truth
about the outside world is revealed
we also learn about the alden people
their history
and the way that the rest of the world
perceives the aliens
eldians are of course the only people in
the world with the ability to become
titans
and for that reason they are both feared
and hated
by most other nations the aldians are
referred to as devils
and they are victims of blatant
discrimination and racism at the hands
of the marlands in particular
the merlions blame aliens for oppressing
other nations historically
but the current generation of eldians
are being made to suffer for the alleged
sins of their ancestors
and that is profoundly unfair but even
so
aaron and the other scouts try their
best to find
a peaceful solution they secretly
infiltrate
the continent and try to negotiate with
the other nations
in an attempt to co-exist peacefully
nevertheless
it eventually becomes apparent to aaron
that no matter what the aldians and
parodies
try to do they will never be able to
appease
the outside world the other nations will
always be afraid of the islanders
and their titan powers and they won't
stop until
every aldian on the island is dead even
the aldians on the continent
the countrymen of the islanders blamed
the aldians for all of their problems
and so many of these mainland aldians
support attacking and destroying
parodies
these mainland aldians are hoping beyond
hope that if they demonstrate their
loyalty towards their own oppressors by
supporting the destruction of their
fellow aliens on the island
they will finally be shown some mercy by
the marlenes
over the course of the past 100 years
the marlans in particular have instilled
such extreme self-hatred into the hearts
of the aldians
that they have internalized the very
racism and oppression that they have
been subject to
for at least a hundred years aaron's
half-brother zeke
is the perfect embodiment of this very
thing
zeke is an aldian who grew up on the
continent and he was so victimized by
marlene oppression that he came to
believe that the only way to save the
world
was to bring about the end of his own
people tragically
the aldians like zeke who suffered for
their entire lives at the hands of the
marlene oppressors
started hating themselves to such an
extent that they decided to do exactly
what the merlions wanted
they decided to destroy their own people
but not aaron when he came to understand
that no peaceful solution was possible
and that no matter what happens the
outside world would keep attacking
parodies until every alden on the island
was dead
aaron refused to lie down and take it
since there is no hope for peace only
two options remain
aaron can either sit back and allow
everyone he ever knew and cared about on
the island to be destroyed by invaders
from the outside world
or he can fight back and destroy the
outside world
to such an extent that no invader will
ever be able to threaten parodies again
aaron of course
chooses the latter option he decides to
destroy the outside world
before the outside world can destroy
parodies
in order to execute this plan aaron is
forced to reject his closest friends
including armin and mikasa and he is
forced to betray his half-brother zeke
he even uses the attack titan's ability
to pass down future memories
to ensure that his plan comes to
fruition in fact
we eventually learned that when grisha
was having second thoughts about killing
the rhys family and capturing the
founding titan power
it was actually aaron from the future
who convinced grisha to go
through with his plan and according to
what grisha says to future zeke
after he consumes the founding titan
power he has seen even more awareness
future memories
and they are absolutely terrifying aaron
was the one who yearned to be free since
birth
aaron was the one who refused to sit
back and allow his people to be
punished for the sins of their ancestors
and aaron was the one who willingly
decided to initiate
the rumbling for 100 years the outside
world has feared the rumbling
king carl fritz the king who had built
the walls in the first place
threatened the outside world not to
interfere in the affairs of the island
he created the walls and he filled them
with millions of colossal titans as a
deterrent
he said that if forces from the outside
world ever did attack parodies
the millions of colossal titans would be
released and the entire world would be
flattened
during an apocalyptic event known as the
rumbling
however the outside world and marlei in
particular
did not get the message instead of
avoiding the island for fear of the
rumbling
they kept plotting new attacks in order
to take the founding titan power and
remove the threat of the rumbling from
the equation
altogether instead of deterring foreign
nations from interfering in the affairs
of the island
the rumbling is part of the reason why
the outside world was so intent on
attacking parodies
ironically the outside world's
determination to prevent the rumbling
is the very thing that makes the
rumbling inevitable
because as we know aaron decides that
the only way to save the island
is to use the rumbling to destroy
everything else
after making a deal with emir fritz the
original founding titan
aaron releases the walled titans and
takes on a new
absolutely gigantic and terrifying titan
form
aaron then leads this army of colossal
titans
into a massive attack on the military
forces of marley
and the other allied nations who had
assembled the world's most
powerful war fleet a fleet whose
intention was to destroy
parodies although his first target is
the fleet
it is generally understood that aaron's
plan is to flatten the entire
outside world unless aaron is secretly
planning something else that we are not
aware of
we can assume that after destroying the
enemy armed forces
he will continue to destroy everything
in sight
including of course innocent civilians
who have done nothing wrong
with this aaron's character has come
full
circle aaron has gone from a young boy
who swore to kill
every single titan in order to rescue
humanity to the leader of a titan
army whose goal is the destruction of
humanity
or at least the vast majority of
humanity
and yet through all of this staggering
character development
and it is definitely one of the most
impressive examples of character
development
in anime and manga aaron has remained
consistent
in terms of his personality and his
life's purpose
despite going from someone who wanted to
save humanity from the titans to someone
who is apparently determined to destroy
most of humanity with the help of the
titans aaron has not
become a hypocrite aaron is still driven
by the same
basic desires as he was when he was a
child
he just wants to be free and he just
wants to protect
the people he loves when he was younger
in the first part of the story
seeking freedom and protecting his loved
ones meant that aaron had to fight the
titans
in this second part of the story the
older and more mature
aaron realizes that the only way to be
free and protect his loved ones on
parodies
is to annihilate the outside world using
the titans
in that sense aaron who is of course the
protagonist
is both a villain and a hero someone
willing to kill millions of innocent
people no matter what his reason may be
can definitely be classified as a
villain at the same time
from the subjective perspective of the
aldeans and parodies
aaron can also be seen as a hero and
that is exactly how the jaegerists see
him
this is because the jaegerists believe
much like aaron seems to believe
that destroying the outside world is the
only way to protect themselves
and literally everyone they ever loved
and cared about
it's either destroyed the world or be
destroyed
by it aaron appears to have chosen to
take upon himself
the horrible burden of killing millions
so that the aliens on the island could
live in peace
he will take all the guilt and all the
blame
while ensuring the survival of the
islanders by any means
necessary this shocking character
development that aaron has undergone
since the beginning of the story
is as incredible as it is tragic
to achieve his lifelong goals of being
free
and protecting his loved ones aaron had
to become
everything that he hated aaron is now in
a position
where he has to put millions of innocent
civilians through the same tragedy and
trauma that he himself was put through
as a child and he has to take all that
guilt and all that blame onto himself so
that his loved ones on parodies could
finally
live in peace what an amazing personal
story
and yet what a deeply tragic story at
the same time
no matter what ultimately happens in
attack on titan and no matter what aaron
ultimately decides to do
he is already one of the most
fascinating characters in the history of
anime for me
personally it's hard to imagine any
character undergoing such a drastic
shift throughout the story and yet
somehow still remaining true to his
original goals
and convictions a big part of why this
works
is of course the cruel nature of the
attack on titan world
a world where you pretty much have to be
a villain to some
in order to be a hero to others and the
other part of it is the amazing way in
which isayama has written aaron as a
character
allowing him to develop in shocking and
unbelievable ways
while still remaining true to his inner
core aaron's
incredible and yet tragic character
progression
is one of the most powerful aspects of
attack on titan
and it is my belief that when everything
is said and done aaron will become one
of the most
memorable anime and manga characters on
par with the likes of lelouch
meruem like yagami simone from guren
lagon
and guts from berserk definitely let me
know what you guys think about the
tragic life of aaron
and his shocking character development
down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more videos like it please leave
a like to let me know
it really does help and if you're new to
anime
pro or you just haven't subscribed make
this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime upper patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thanks to all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata alolan
adam the world
steelers acquired respect pate heffa
jonathan king
brandon aviles papa smurf the school bus
king riser emperor otaku ricardo
martinez
thomas jones kin mano michael hyde
and jaden the vector and i can't forget
all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan
jason wilson kings eldris and anatoly
kazatsky
on hell cruise cricket xp joe stanton
very gucci alicia octor jessica kayla
fond
hinokami and water bonnie parks zodiac
12
rathune de ora kraken rls and
deadly saint if you enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value to you
please consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you